Whoa!
Wait, where am I?
Oh, hey!
I was just like, wait a minute, where am I?
Professional streamer, by the way.
You guys wanna know how professional I was?
For those who just got here and was not at pre-chat, basically, I may or may not have procrastinated when it came to activating my invite that Mattman gave me.
Because I was like, it'll be fine.
Mattman said it's like unlimited invites.
As long as I click accept, I should be like, it'll be fine.
And then I clicked on it this morning, and it was like, this code has been claimed.
I was like, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
I was like, wait a minute.
I thought it was unlimited.
Unlimited means that it's not limited.
I should be able to claim it.
And then I messaged Matt, and I was like, Matt, I fucked up.
I fucked up.
I procrastinated.
I know you gave me this code last week, but I'm redeeming it now, because I have a stream today.
I know I fucked up.
I know you gave it to me last week, and I could've, you know, claimed it any other of those days.
But you don't understand.
You don't understand, Matt.
That was so eepy.
Every day I was just so eepy.
Anyway.
And then Matt gave me a bunch of links, but then they were all claimed.
I didn't understand.
How were they all claimed?
I got sent five different links, and none of them worked.
And then we messaged SageM, but he was streaming, so he's usually not online on Discord when he's usually not online on Discord when he's streaming.
So I was like, uh oh.
I have an hour left to stream.
I have an hour left!
And then I messaged BrawlPro.
I was like, BrawlPro SOS, do you have a code?
And then luckily he sent me three links.
And the third link worked.
Thank God.
So we got in!
We got in 2xKO!
And this is why you need to network.
Thank God.
Networking has saved me yet again!
Anyway, today we are going to be trying out Riot's new fighting game 2xKO.
Basically, it is a fighting game that uses League of Legends characters.
I liked how people were like, Oh my God, I can't believe Doki plays League.
I do not play League.
So I have zero knowledge on who any of these characters are.
Except for Ahri.
I only know the existence of Ahri because she is like the character.
You know how in Overwatch there's Mercy and she's like the character of Overwatch?
All I know is that Ahri is like the character in League.
You know what I'm talking about?
That's why I know about...
That's how I know about Ahri.
Also, a little bit of fun fact.
The FNAF...
Oh, so by the way, I'll be using keyboard for...
I'll be using... I thought it was because of Faker.
No, you guys all know why Ahri is very popular and it's not because of Faker.
Anyway, I'll also be using keyboard because I try to unpack everything and like I don't know where I put my leverless controller.
I don't know where it is.
I have so many boxes guys.
I...
I have so many boxes.
I don't remember where I packed it.
So, we're going to be using keyboard because I don't know.
I can't... I don't know where I put it and I can't be bothered to unpack right now.
Also, another update.
Another update regarding...
So, a little life update on...
the FNAF VOD.
So, if you guys didn't know, my Five Nights at Freddy's Into the Pit video stream got age-restricted.
So, what does that mean?
That basically means you have to be 18 or older to watch that stream.
So, I messaged my YouTube guy when it got age-restricted because I was like, what the fuck happened?
Like, why?
Like, is it the title?
And...
Okay.
Alright.
Then...
And he was like, it's not the title.
And I was like, wait, then what is it?
And he was like, it appears to be due to profanity.
And I was like, oh, did I fuck up?
Did I swear too much in the first 10 minutes?
And then, I'm gonna read you what he wrote to me.
He was like, um...
I don't have specifics on exact timestamps, but...
there was definitely a lot of profanity through Some
moderate is usually okay.
But excessive profanity, especially if it's a lot in the short time window, can lead to age restrictions.
And I was like...
More than usual?
More than unusual streams?
That has to be a record.
That really has to be a record for me.
I said a lot of profanity on my stream.
But for some reason, this particular stream had the most... had so much profanity in such a short amount of time span that it got age restricted.
And it's not just one exact moment, it's throughout the stream.
So I may or may not have went just a little bit too far.
And like, I just want you guys to know, I've never been age restricted before.
Like, I've never been like...
I've been like demonetized before.
But I've never had an R18 age restriction.
There has been demonetization, but never has it been R18 restricted because of the profanity!
That is like... that is a for me!
I was so surprised!
I just love how my YouTube guy was like, there was a lot of profanity throughout the stream!
Because he was like, I can't give you timestamps!
There was just...
There was just so much!
There was so many!
So...
So yeah!
That's why... so they're like...
He was like, sorry, I really...
I didn't do anything about it, so yeah!
Enjoy my R18 into the pit stream!
My very first R18 stream!
And it was for FNAF!
It was for fucking FNAF!
I can't believe it!
Also, how do you guys like my acoustics right now?
The soundproofing... not soundproof, sorry, the echo proofing for today's stream!
Today I put up more... like I...
I put up more stuff so there should be like less...
even less echo now.
So like I actually put up some some corner foam, some acoustic panels and everything.
There's still like more foam I have to put up.
But like, it's getting there.
I'm a little bit worried that when I get the plushies out, like it's just gonna go backwards, so like it's gonna get...
I feel like...
I feel like the moment I like...
remove the plushies, like everything is just gonna reset itself.
So... so...
I have yet to remove the plushies on the floor because I am...
a little worried about that.
Anyway, I don't know how long I'll be streaming today.
As you guys know, I'm not really a fighting game streamer.
I did sign up for the next Sajam Slam for Street Fighter.
Because I did say like, oh yeah, let's run it back.
So like, we'll see.
I'm not sure...
I'm not sure if I'm gonna make it in this time around, because like I know there's like a lot of people.
A lot of people that signed up for the Street Fighter Sajam Slam.
So, we'll see.
We'll see.
I hope I do get in.
I really wanna be on the same team again.
With Team Brawl Pro.
I hope I get them again.
It was really fun.
But yeah!
We'll see.
Anyway, I have not a lot of experience in fighting games.
Tekken was...
Okay, I was gonna say...
What was that other fighting game?
The one with...
The one with the anime... Skullgirls!
Skullgirls was the very first time I actually tried a fighting game on stream.
But even then, it wasn't like... I didn't really play... I only did like one stream of it.
But Tekken was like the very first fighting game where I actually tried to understand the combos and everything.
Yeah, it might be like two combos.
But I tried.
I...
I did... I did try to understand it, okay?
I did try to figure out the combos.
And I did...
I got a... I bought a leverless controller and every... Okay, no.
Actually, I didn't buy one.
The... What was it called?
The... Like, Sajam Slam...
Oh my gosh!
It wasn't even like... It's not even Sajams.
It was like...
It was like a leverless controller company sent me one for free.
So, like, I even got one for free too.
So, I actually took it very seriously for Sajam Slam.
Yeah, the snack box!
Yes, yes, yes!
Junk food arcades.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They sent me a free one.
And everything.
So, yeah.
I don't know where I put it.
So, we're not going to be using one...
using it right now.
I just don't know where it is.
I'm sorry.
I don't know where I put it.
There's so many boxes!
So, we'll see how it goes.
Like I said, I don't really know much about League of Legends or, like, League characters.
And, like, I don't... I'm actually going in fully blind on, like, this game.
But I have heard good things about it.
I have heard some good things regarding Riot's take on the fighting game genre.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let me...
Where is it?
Okay.
I forgot to...
It's called Lion.
Like the EXE.
It's not even called, like...
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
Don't tell me it's only window capture again.
Let me see.
Oh, no.
It's because I haven't even shown it.
Okay, there you go.
Please don't tell me it's window capture.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
I don't know who the fuck these people are.
To be fair, League has, like, a billion characters.
They've been around for, like, how many years already?
Like, 15 plus years?
They have, like, a billion fucking characters in League in general.
So, it's like, how do you keep track of this?
I mean, good for them.
They don't have to... Technically, they don't have to, like, make new characters.
They can just drag, like, League of Legends characters and just put it in.
So, they don't... Technically, they don't have to really design new concepts or anything.
They just, like, grab it from a pre-existing uh... pre-existing game.
Logging you in.
Maybe I should have logged in first.
I'm just like, why is this taking so long?
Two hundred...
Yeah, that's actually insane.
Two hundred... I'm always wondering, like, how do you balance that?
Like, how do you balance two hundred characters?
Like, what if, like...
That's... that's almost...
That has to be impossible.
You don't.
Yeah.
Do you just, like, uh... like, what happens to, like, the shitty characters then?
Do they just...
Like, you can't really one-trick a character if you think about it.
Because, like, um, they just never...
They release it and they just never touch it again.
Like...
Devs just never do anything to the character after they released it and then they're abandoned.
And the patch notes are only, like, their favorite characters, like Ahri.
And that's it.
...
Yeah, I was just thinking.
Also, does it usually take this long to log me in?
I'm like...
They balance the game every two weeks?
That sounds fucking terrible.
Like, that actually sounds terrible.
The meta will decide?
Wait, how do they decide the meta?
Oh.
They usually... You might... I need to restart the game.
Okay, I'll restart the game.
I'm like, wait a minute.
Why am I not locked in yet?
Okay.
I'll restart the game, guys.
Alright.
Play.
Where is it?
Why is it not...
Why does it not play?
Hello?
Did I fuck it up already?
You know what?
I'm me.
I won't be surprised if I fucked it up already.
Wait, I'm logged out?
How did I got logged out?
I already got logged out!
What did I I just closed the game and it logged me out!
Alright, give me a sec, guys.
I'm going back in.
Play.
It's not even my fault!
This wasn't even my fault!
It just...
It just didn't work.
Oh, there it is!
Missing.
I am... I'm new.
Or haven't played then go easy on me.
I'm new.
I like how competitor is like, I have a hat.
I don't like that.
I'm a competitor.
Do you see my hat?
Alright.
What?
Ooh.
Thank you for joining Alpha Lab.
Alright, let's see.
Progression.
Where are the characters?
Wait.
2, 4.
Oh, there's only 2, 4.
Oh, there's only 6 characters.
I just thought there'd be more.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, is that me?
Can I change myself?
I want a hat too.
Oh!
Okay.
I want a hat.
Alright.
Oh my god!
Oh, okay.
I'm not rich enough.
Okay.
Let's see.
Blue and yellow.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Hands.
Feet.
No.
Alright.
Oh.
What's...
Okay.
Body.
You gotta unlock it.
What about this?
Oh!
Wait, there's more customization!
Alright.
Uh...
Are these just eyebrows?
Oh, they're eyebrows.
Alright.
I'm gonna start mewing.
No, you don't understand.
This is very important.
I need a mew.
Alright.
Let's see.
Uh...
Eyebrow color?
That's not right.
What is this?
Are these nose?
Oh, they're details!
Okay.
Are there eye bags?
To show how dead inside I am?
I might as well be goth too.
You know what?
Yeah.
Let's do it.
Let's be fucking goth.
Let's fucking go.
Let's go.
Alright.
There we go.
Hairstyle.
Wait.
Why is it still brown?
Hello?
Alright.
Yes!
That looks goth enough.
That looks emo enough.
Oh, I have to double click it.
Alright.
Oh shit.
No.
No beard.
I'm here to be...
I'm here to be emo.
I am dead inside right now.
Alright.
Let's see.
You know what?
Yeah.
Okay.
If I'm gonna be... Oh.
Curvy and sporty.
Whoa.
What if I want to be curvy and sporty?
Okay.
Let's see.
Whoa.
Sorry.
I'm too absorbed with the jiggle there.
Okay.
Uh...
Yeah.
Face, hairstyle, body, eyes.
You know what?
I should wear something that fits my soul.
Uh...
There we go.
This fits how I feel in the inside.
Uh...
And then... There we go.
There we go.
I'll be a goth slash emo kid.
Nice.
Oh.
Thank god.
I was like...
Did I save it?
Also, do you guys like my username?
DokiBirdReal?
I'm... I'm real.
Alright.
Nice.
How do I play?
Fight.
Okay.
Play.
Hashtag real.
That's right.
I'm real.
Alright.
There's Kanyu.
Okay.
No.
Don't follow me.
I don't know how to play this game.
I...
Don't follow me.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know what I'm...
Don't follow me.
Alright.
Find a match.
I don't want to fight you.
You look like you know what you're doing.
It's not fair.
He looks like he knows what he's doing.
I... I don't know what I'm doing.
I...
I don't know what I'm doing.
Okay.
Ari.
Huh?
I'll be blue.
I'll be blue, Ari.
I don't fucking... You know what?
I'm going to mirror match you.
You seem to know what you're doing.
I'll be blue.
Press attack buttons rapidly Press attack buttons rapidly for devastating combos.
Wait.
I shouldn't... Why didn't it go straight in?
Why didn't I do the tutorial?
I'm like...
I don't even know the controls.
I can't even button match.
Because I don't have my libraus controller.
Why didn't it go straight into this?
Why did I do this?
Why did I do this to myself?
Alright.
I'm learning the hard way.
I don't need... how do I... what are the buttons?
I made the fucking... what is... how do you attack?
Please me!
I don't even know how to attack!
Please!
I don't even... please I don't even know how to attack!
I... I don't even know the controls!
I... I...
I don't even feel like what's going on!
Please!
What are the controls?
Holy shit!
I just know how to walk back and jump!
Please!
End my misery!
Please just end my... please just kill me!
No!
Okay, I'm leaving.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
What's going on with my keyboard?
Wait, no, that's you!
That's you!
Okay.
Oh shit!
Sir, sir, I don't know the controls!
Sir, please!
Sir, I'm W-A-S-D!
I'm typing words right now!
I'm typing words!
I'm... I'm... Whoa!
I did that!
Whoa!
I got him hidden!
I'm figuring... what did I press?
I'm pressing everything!
Holy shit!
Why is there a guy there?
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait!
I think I figured it out!
I think I figured out what is the controls!
Okay...
No!
What?
Okay, we're gonna do the tutorial and see what the movesets are.
Um...
I... I hit... I hit a button, guys.
I... I... No, please, no.
Oh my god, he has five wins!
I don't even know what I'm doing!
Where the fuck is the tutorial?
I...
Okay, is it... cabinet?
No.
Oh my god, please.
Where's the training mode?
I don't... I believe...
Oh, back to the menu.
Okay, thank god.
Alright.
I... I... I just see fight!
I... I went straight into fight!
I assumed that was it!
I saw fight and I was like...
That has to be, like, where I go, right?
Okay, what the fuck is S1?
I am on my keyboard right... right now.
Oh no, nobody expected me to be on the keyboard.
Nobody...
I'm pretty sure nobody...
This game was like, why the fuck are you on your keyboard?
I'm sorry!
Oh my god, alright.
Okay, I didn't know!
I thought I keyboard!
Alright.
Okay, let's see.
I must... I'm gonna find my... where's my roller?
Okay, wait, I have my PS5.
Okay.
I got my PS5 controller.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
I'm plugging in the controller.
I've given up.
I've already... I've given up on the... on the keyboard.
I... I've... I know my place now.
I... I know my place.
Wait, I can't...
Oh, there it is!
Training!
Tutorial!
Thank god!
Wait, you play on keyboard?
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, dash.
Okay, I dash.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
Alright, JJ.
Oh, it's JJ!
Okay.
JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ.
JJ, JJ, JJ.
Okay.
Alright.
Those are the moves.
JJ, JJ, JJ.
JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ.
JJ, JJ, JJ, JJ.
Alright.
We figured it out, guys.
Now I know how he hit me.
Oh, K, K, K.
K, K, K.
Wait.
Oh, that's so sick.
Alright.
Guys, we figured it out.
Guys, we figured it out how to...
how to do moves now.
Alright.
Heavy combo.
I mean, it's really pretty.
Graphics are nice.
Some of the alpha is...
I assume it's going to get better too, the graphics.
Alright.
Okay, L, L, L, okay.
Nice.
Are there actual beginners still in this game?
Like...
I know, like, you know, I know Alpha's gonna end in, like, two...
It's gonna end in two days, but, like, there has to be, like...
There has to be, like, you know, beginners like me too, right?
Oh, throw!
No.
No!
Oh.
I know how to move.
Block.
That's right.
Do you guys see that new fighting game where it's, like, all jiggle physics?
And then, like, whenever you get hit on, it's, like, get a hit on the...
And they're all ladies.
And then when you get hit on, it, like, slo-mo's it.
Oh.
Do you guys see it?
It was on Twitter.
And people were like, why does, like, every hit cause a slo-mo?
Like, you know why.
Did any of my mods see it so they could link it?
I thought that was so funny.
I was like, what the fuck?
Alright.
Let's see.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Why did the volume...
Why is there no more music?
Oh, there it is.
What?
Oh!
Oh, it's cause I muted my- muted it myself.
Uh, how do I do this?
Um.
Huh?
Oh, fuck.
Let me hit you!
Guys, I'm bringing- I'm bringing my- I'm using a 60% keyboard.
I- Give me a sec.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna grab my keyboard.
Uh, it must be because I'm using a 60% keyboard.
It must be it.
I don't have- By the way, I don't even have arrow keys on that keyboard.
I-
There was, like, no arrow keys.
I had to press two extra buttons to get the arrow keys in.
Oh my god.
I have no arrow keys on this.
I had to, like, I had to press, like, function key.
I had to hold function key and then press, like, alt menu.
Like- Okay.
Oh yeah, there it is!
Yeah, Battle Queen!
Battle Queen.
That's the- That's the game I was talking about!
Alright.
Also, sound, guys.
Everything okay?
Sound-wise?
Alright, where the fuck is the- Okay, there it is.
Alright.
Now I have arrow keys now.
Okay, that was a lot easier.
Alright.
Did I not do it?
Oh!
Okay.
I did it.
Alright.
Uhh...
Did I do that?
No, I didn't do that correctly.
Huh?
Oh there you go.
It's so many, like, cutscenes though.
I just noticed that too.
It feels like all of it is, like, special.
Everything is, like, special in general.
Uhh...
Eh.
Here we go.
Here's a kiss!
That's a lot of- We are not supers.
Oh, swap partners?
Hold.
Oh, that's... oh!
I thought that said queue.
Okay, assists have a two-second cooldown.
Oh, that's what I did before!
You must wait... wait, okay, two sec... is it two seconds yet?
Okay.
Come on!
Give me the other assist!
There we go.
Okay.
Do I need one more?
Okay, one more assist.
Oh!
Tap team while assist is...
Huh?
Oh!
Is that?
Okay.
That's how you do it.
Huh?
And then I stay.
Okay.
I get it.
And then I stay.
And then...
Oh!
No!
I have to wait again!
Okay.
And then... I'm in.
Okay, tap team and hit opponent.
Okay.
And then hit.
Oh, that's so cool!
This reminds me of Marvel versus Capcom.
Wait, no.
Is it Marvel versus...
Yeah, Marvel versus Capcom.
That's what it reminds me of.
Like the...
The tag team.
Okay.
Hello?
What's going on with my keyboard?
I was like...
No!
Do it again!
Wait, you're fighting back?
Okay.
Wait!
No!
Don't fight back!
You're not supposed to!
Okay.
When being hit by a combo.
All right.
Did I do it?
No?
Okay, I didn't get hit.
And then...
Did I do it?
How do I do this?
Huh?
Oh, while being hit.
Okay.
I'm spamming it, but it's not letting me.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
My food is here.
No!
I have to do this.
This is not what I wanted!
Oh, there you go!
I did it!
Okay.
It has to be...
Oh, it's a counter!
Oh, so I have to time it correctly!
Try and hit me.
No!
Not like that!
Nice.
Okay.
I got it.
Okay, I have to time it perfectly.
Alright.
Guys, I think I'm ready.
I think I figured it out, guys.
Okay.
Casual.
Maybe this time.
Oh, I'm alone.
Okay.
Guess I'm alone.
Guys, maybe this time.
Alright.
Shirley!
Any friends?
Any friends here?
Lonely, Mr. Lonely.
I have nobody.
I'm pretty sure I'm literally the only beginner in this entire game right now.
I'm pretty sure, like, the last alpha codes were sent out, like, a week ago.
And I just got in.
I just got in today just for this stream.
There's no way!
How am I alone?
Alright.
Fuck this.
I'm ranking my own match.
There has to be dragoons who got in.
Right?
Alright.
Alright, this is my private lobby.
Um...
How are you guys gonna find it?
Wait, how do you guys find my private lobby?
Um...
What?
I don't even know.
I don't know how you guys can find my private lobby.
What's the ID?
That's a very good question.
What is my ID?
Oh, there it is!
Guys, guys, I found it!
Alright.
Alright, this is the ID.
Guys.
Alright.
Uh...
Training...
Okay, join cabinet.
Alright, guys.
Get in here.
Ready up to play solo.
Wait, no!
I need friends.
Guys!
2v2!
Guys, 2v...
Get in here!
I see you guys!
2v2!
2v2, guys!
Alright, I'm ready.
Alright.
What's this nerd that doesn't even have an avatar?
Alright, everybody.
Watch me get...
Don't call me in!
Okay, Alan?
Don't...
Don't call me in!
You go fight as long as you can, and then when you die, then you call me in!
You know what?
I'll...
I'll be...
I...
Alan, you got this!
You got this, Alan!
I believe in you!
I literally have no idea who any of these characters are, except...
Except for Ahri.
That's literally the only...
The only character I know.
Fury...
Pulse?
What does that mean?
Don't tag me in, Alan!
You tag me in when you're fucking dead!
Alright, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I love you, Doki!
You always make me laugh, even when I'm sad.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
I really appreciate that!
I'm glad that...
You've been enjoying my streams!
Alright.
Oh my god!
Strong woman!
Oh, thank god I'm not first!
Go, Alan!
Do your thing!
Holy shit!
This game looks so fast compared to, like, me on the tutorial!
Me in the tutorial, this game was like...
Oh, Alan!
Don't you dare tag me in!
Keep fighting!
Yeah!
Oh, Alan!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
You see?
He actually knows how to play!
Oh my god!
I hit him!
Don't use your assist!
You have no assist!
I like how the other team, they're actually, like, you know, working together and like...
Bro, he's just 1v2!
If you...
If you call me in, I will never... I'm kicking you off the team.
Alan, no!
Alan!
Yay!
Wait, Alan, call me in at the last moment.
When she's like 1HP, call me in when she's 1HP, okay?
Not when you're 1HP, when she's 1HP.
Alright, nice.
Nice.
Not yet, not yet, not yet.
Almost there, Alan.
Just like two more hits, two more hits.
Oh, call me in, call me in!
No, Alan, you're not supposed to die!
That's okay, I'll finish the job.
Oh, shit!
Alan, what do I do?
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit, it's not what I expected.
I did it!
I did it, guys!
I clutched it for Alan!
Guys, I clutched it when he needed me the most!
Alan, don't call me in yet.
Not yet.
Not yet, Alan.
Wait, I can help!
Watch this!
Am I doing anything, Alan?
Oh!
Alan, I did that!
I can do that again!
Am I doing it?
Alan, no!
Alan, wait!
She's full HP, Alan!
Okay, don't worry, I got this.
I got this, don't worry.
I... Alan...
Oh, shit, I got this!
Oh, super!
Am I doing it?
My game crashed.
Guys, I did it!
I won!
The whole lobby crashed!
Oh, my God!
I did it!
I helped!
The all was so strong!
That it crashed the entire lobby!
That's actually crazy!
I can't believe it crashed the entire lobby!
I was like, am I doing it?
Am I doing it?
Yes, Toki!
Yes, sweetie, you did it!
You did it, sweetie!
I was just too powerful!
Alright...
Wait...
We gotta...
Okay...
We gotta cancel, so I...
Because you guys don't even have the lobby code!
I forgot to give you guys the lobby code!
Holy shit!
Okay!
Next scene!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Peak of meeting timing!
Alright!
Here we go again!
Here we go!
Wait, no!
I don't...
Alright, guys!
I can't be the first person in the...
Alright, Flux!
Oh my god!
Team Goth Emo!
Versus...
Holy shit!
Versus the ner...
The tech...
The nerds!
The nerds versus the goth emos!
Oh, I cancelled it!
No, no, no!
No!
Guys!
Get off the cabinet!
I'm not even in!
Guys!
No!
Team...
Guys!
Guys, I wanna play!
Please!
Guys!
I wanna play!
Please!
Okay..
Nice!
Alright!
Guys!
Win me!
Alright!
Alright...
Don't worry!
This time...
This time, I...
I did it correctly!
Wait, where's my goth kid?!
Where's my goth kid?!
Alright...
This time...
This time, I know what I'm doing!
I know what I'm doing this time!
Don't worry!
What?
Alright, nice.
Technically, I... Wait, they have skins?
Wait!
Wait, that's not fair!
Why do you have skins?
Wait a minute!
That's not fair!
TeamGothEmo destroys the arcade's only caps.
Doki reckoning.
Thank you for the super chat.
Luka, thank you, thank you.
Oh, do I get to pick?
Wait, they both have skins!
Wait!
These fucking nerds!
Alright.
Who's fighting first?
Aww, that's so cute!
Oh shit!
Swap me out!
No!
I don't... I don't...
No, please!
I don't know how to... I forgot how to do it!
Darius...
You should've swapped me out.
I tried so hard to tag!
I... I panicked!
I was panicking!
It's okay!
Darius!
You know what you're...
Oh, Darius does not know what he... does not know what he's doing!
Oh!
I can help you!
I did it!
Oh!
You're welcome!
I did that!
Oh my god!
Look at me go!
I'm gonna keep doing it!
Watch this!
In two seconds!
I'm... I'm coming in soon!
Don't worry!
Right here!
That's right!
Yeah!
That...
I did it!
Oh my god!
Oh...
No!
Don't get hit!
Class!
I did so much!
Okay, nice.
Don't worry!
I'm here to help!
I got you!
I don't know what's going on, but I got you!
Wait!
Oh, that's you!
Okay!
I'm going in!
Assist!
Assisting!
You're welcome!
Don't worry!
Here I come again!
That's fucking right!
Wait!
I got knocked off!
Where am I?
Here I come in again!
I'm doing it!
Oh, it's okay.
I blocked it!
I blocked the damage!
Don't worry, man!
I got you!
I'm... I'm coming over again!
Don't worry!
I blocked more damage!
Oh!
You were supposed to live!
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa!
That's fucking right!
Alright, that's what you deserve.
I let you... whoa, whoa, whoa, no!
Oh my god, please.
Please.
It's okay.
I know what I'm doing.
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
Not cookies!
Not the cookies!
We were so close!
I think, like, I felt like, you know, like, you know, it's impossible to clutch when, like, when, like, it's a 1v2, you know, for me.
It's sort of really difficult to do it when it's a 1v2, guys.
Like, like, guys, I don't know how much more I could do.
I don't...
Like, how much more could I do, chat?
Wait, what about me?
Do I get to play?
Oh, they left the game.
Nice.
Okay.
Wait, how do I...
How do I join this game?
Like, join cabinet queue.
Oh, okay.
Wait, I want to be in it.
I want to be in it.
Except...
Alright.
I'm going to be on my team.
Wait, it's 1v1?
Alright.
You know what?
Let's try something new.
Wait, it's 1v1?
Okay, you know what?
I want to try strong woman.
And then strong man.
Alright.
Big woman, big man.
I have no idea if this is meta or not, but...
The moment I win a game, it's over.
I've downloaded this entire game in my head.
I am a muscle team.
How can I lose?
I put it all on strength.
Look at her.
She's like twice the size of his team.
Him alone is like twice... Look at him!
Look how tall she is!
I'm going to fucking squish you.
I'm going to... Oh, shit.
Okay.
He brought a knife.
He brought a sword.
Okay.
He knows what he's doing.
This is... This is an issue, guys.
He brought a sword to a fight.
I have a fucking shield and arms.
Like, what am I supposed to do?
I...
What am I... I can't even move!
Please!
Oh, okay.
What?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Just block?
I've never even blocked in Tekken!
Oh, I blocked!
I blocked.
I'm dead.
Okay, watch this.
There we go.
That's a block.
That's also a block.
And then... Oh!
Please!
The man needs to get one hit in!
I just went one hit!
Holy shit!
Yes!
Oh, my God!
That's 200 hits!
Where am I?
Oh, I don't know!
I don't know where I am!
What the fuck?
This is not fair!
All I have are my arms!
And he has a sword!
This should not be legal!
Okay.
All right.
Block.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I'm on the other side.
How did I get to the other side?
I... How does he have so much range?
How?
How does he?
How does he have so much range?
What?
What did I do?
I did that.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm hitting.
I'm... I'm doing stuff.
I'm not doing anything anymore.
I'm on...
Where am I?
Am I in the air?
I'm getting... I'm being made into sushi?
Okay.
All right.
It's okay.
I know how to block.
The moment I touch the ground, it's over for you.
The moment I touch the ground, I will start blocking.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Let me at least block once.
That's all I ask.
I just... I just want to block once.
Oh, my God.
I got... I got the block, guys.
I got the block.
It's okay.
I... I managed to block a little bit.
I just won.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck...
He's been... He's been juggling me and everything.
What... What the fuck?
Guys... Guys, can we have our tag team fight again?
Guys, let's... Guys, let's tag team everybody.
Guys, let's...
We should... We should tag team, guys.
How do we set it to tag team?
Oh my god.
That was...
That was sad.
That was an attempt.
How are they not tag teaming?
Sorry, that was my...
Wait.
What the fuck?
Oh.
No, that's the...
This is not tag team?
Guys, leave.
This is my lobby.
Guys, this is my lobby.
I wanna be...
Be in the big leagues.
Oh, can I get down this couch?
Oh.
Wait.
Guys.
We don't need them.
We can have our own team.
Oh my god.
Team Emo and Goth.
We're back.
Team Goth Emo is back.
All right, Flux.
All in on you, Flux.
Okay.
Apparently...
What's his name?
Sam...
Or is it this guy?
Oh, one caught.
Why can't we just have two sword guys?
Okay.
I think Ahri was like the best I've ever done.
So we're gonna...
We're gonna go with Ahri.
All right.
I believe in you.
We're team Emo-Goth.
What could go wrong?
It was so nice of Toki to set up a lobby for drag ghouls to play together.
Thank you for the super chat cast.
Thank you.
Oh, where have we not gone yet?
We haven't fought in the tavern yet.
I wanna fight in the tavern.
All right.
Is Yasuo the really strong?
Is Yasuo really strong?
I mean, he has a fucking sword.
So I assume so.
All right.
I'm gonna tag myself out.
Make sure.
All right.
Nice.
All right, guys.
I'm playing...
I'm Yasuo right now.
So I'm pressing J, J, J, J, J, J, J, J, um...
Left arrow.
J, J, J, K, J, J...
Oh my god.
I'm so good, guys.
Holy shit.
Did you guys see that combo I just did?
That's...
That's right M right there.
He's just like in league.
Is he just as hated?
You know what's funny?
I saw a tweet.
Yes, I can like multitask while I'm playing.
Um...
But like, the funniest shit was that like...
Like some FGC people were like, oh, I've never played league before.
So I guess I'll check it out now that like I've checked out like 2x KO.
And then so...
So...
So they were like...
But tag me in!
No!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Wait!
Get in!
I might still...
There we go.
I did it.
Don't worry.
I'll help.
I'm gonna help you.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Just don't tag me.
Don't worry.
I'll come back.
I'll come back right now.
It's okay.
Right here.
Oh.
Okay.
It's okay.
We're fine.
We are not fine.
We're not fine right now.
Please.
Oh.
It's okay.
I'm dead.
Okay.
We're fine.
I can't.
I can barely.
Sometimes.
Sometimes I don't know what's going on.
I don't know if you guys noticed that.
Sometimes.
I just.
I just don't know what's going on sometimes.
All right.
Don't worry.
I'm here.
That's right.
I did it.
I did the thing.
All right.
Don't worry.
We're going to get rid of big woman.
Oh my god!
Did I do it?
Did I do the thing?
Oh!
Oh, he missed!
He missed!
Oh, I got you!
Tag me in!
Guys, he tagged me in.
Did you guys see?
Did you guys... Did you guys see me?
Did you guys see me tag?
I got tagged in.
He got lost in the sauce.
It is combo now.
Guys, I got tagged in.
Guys.
Wait, I want to be sword guy.
Alright.
Alright, I got this.
Don't worry.
I saw how he did it.
I'm pretty confident now.
I saw how he... I saw how he played.
So, like, I'm 100% very confident.
Empower your partner with multiple... What is this?
Freestyle... Wait, what should I do?
Pulse... 2x?
Double down?
Is pulse... Pulse lets you auto combo?
Oh, okay.
I'm a beginner.
Alright.
Where have we not fought?
Have we fought?
Have we fought in the sea yet?
I don't think we have.
Okay.
Don't worry, guys.
I saw what he did.
So, like, I'm very confident that I can replicate the exact same thing he did.
The exact same combo.
Okay.
It was like N, M, J, K.
He's like J, J, J, J, K.
K, J, J, J, J, J.
And then M.
And then... Watch this, guys.
Guys, not yet.
Not yet.
Wait, that's not fair.
He's sending people in.
Okay.
Watch.
Oh, my God.
See, I told you.
I knew exactly what he did.
Oh, my God.
Why does he do so much?
How does he do so... What?
How does he do so much damage?
What the fu...
Holy shit.
Oh, I did that.
No.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Tag.
Tag out.
Please.
Get in here.
Why didn't you tag me out, Flux?
Why didn't you watch me die?
He just... He just watched me die like that.
You have to do... No, no, no.
This is my lobby.
In my lobby, I needed him to tag me out.
Can I, like, participate?
He has to tag for me.
Holy shit.
What the fuck is he doing?
How do I participate?
This player can't tag my lobby, my rules.
Oh, my God.
They're, like, double teaming him.
This game plays by my rules.
Exactly.
What the fuck is going on?
What is going...
Okay.
I figured it out.
Did you see that?
I dodged it.
Boom.
That's fucking right.
Whoa.
I did it.
Okay.
I took him to a slaughter.
My bad.
I tagged in just so he could get his shit kicked in.
Don't worry.
I'm helping.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
I got you.
Wait.
Am I in the game?
How did I get in?
Oh, no.
No, I'm not.
He's blue.
I'm...
He's blue and...
Wait.
What am I?
Am I blue?
Is he blue, too?
Wait.
Are they both blue?
Oh, shit.
I'm blue, too.
Oh, God.
That's fucking right.
We try to fucking do fancy shit.
That's fucking...
Oh, no.
Stop.
What the fuck?
Okay.
That's right.
No fancy shit here.
Oh, God.
What the fuck is this break shit?
What is this break shit?
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
I did that.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
But that was pretty cool.
Oh.
No, no, no.
Nice.
Come on.
That's fucking right.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Get shit on.
Oh, shit.
Tag, tag, tag, tag, tag.
Tag.
Oh.
There you go.
I'm hurt.
I don't know what I did, but I'm hurt.
Okay.
Flux.
Look, I worked so hard on that.
Flux, what's going on?
Flux.
Please.
Do something.
Flux.
Flux, please.
Why didn't you do anything?
Oh, my God.
Flux, what the fuck happened?
Bro, what am I doing?
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
Flux got fucking... Whoa.
Oh, God.
Wait.
I got it.
I did that.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
No bats for you.
Oh, no.
What's that?
What the fuck is that?
What?
Bro got destroyed.
No way.
No.
Team got evil.
It's over.
This is why goth and emo kids should never work together.
They're two very different styles.
They're way too different.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
That guy was crazy.
Guys, we need one more.
We need one more.
All I'm saying was that I was clearly the carry, chat.
I was clearly... Okay.
Because that guy beat me with... What's his name?
This guy?
I think I can do it.
I've downloaded him.
I've downloaded this guy.
I think I could do the same thing as he did.
Choose your destination.
All right.
Yeah, I won that one round.
I clutched it.
I, like, literally 1v2'd.
I literally 1v2'd them.
But you are lost.
All right.
This is it.
I will win my first game.
Don't tag me.
You better be doing some sick-ass combos.
What the fuck?
His range is...
Insane.
She can't do anything.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
She has tentacle powers?
What the fuck?
Why can't I do that when I played her?
Don't worry.
I'm gonna help.
I got you.
Right here.
I think I helped you.
Guys, I think I helped.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna help you again.
Oh, shit.
He's dead.
Don't worry.
I saw how he played.
I can do the same thing.
No.
That's right.
I got hidden.
It's over.
Oh, wait.
Why couldn't you do that?
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I don't know what I'm doing, but that's fucking right.
Oh, wait.
I'm getting shit on.
I am getting shit on.
Please.
Please defend me.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
Oh, nice.
That's fucking right.
No.
Not right.
Okay.
How is she doing all that?
Oh, shit.
That's fucking right.
You can't block this, bitch.
Oh, my God.
She blocked it.
Holy shit.
She did it.
She actually blocked it.
I can't believe it.
Oh, my God.
I tanked that for you, bro.
Ari knows what she's doing.
Don't worry.
She'll slowly hit that.
Okay.
She didn't.
Don't worry.
I can do it again.
That's right.
I used my bat.
Don't worry.
Here we go.
He's going to slowly get hit again.
Okay, I okay.
Never mind.
I got okay.
All right.
Whoa.
Oh wait, I'm still in this fight
What the fuck I'm not helping you anymore, bro
This is not fair That's fucking right.
You didn't block your fucking shins.
That's right.
You should have blocked your foot.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
That's fucking right Then blocked your feet again, bitch.
That's fucking right.
Why is she blocking feet?
How did she know?
How do you know?
Oh no.
NOOOOO
Oh my god I almost... I almost did it... by just hitting the feet Just feet only Clutched it.
They didn't block the grips It was so close Alright All right I'm gonna make a new Lobby so new people can join in, guys.
I'll see you guys later.
I'm closing the lobby All right.
Alright, exit to main menu.
Let's create a new lobby for new dragoons.
Alright.
Maybe...
Guys, maybe like... wait.
Maybe other players would be around now.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Did you know someone tags in and gets hit?
Both of you take damage.
Happy birthday, Toki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
I'm alone.
Nobody else is playing this game except for me and you guys.
Except for me and the dragoons.
And no one else is here.
No one else.
Alright.
I guess I'll make my own private lobby again.
Okay.
Private.
There's no babies.
Why is there no babies?
Alright.
Here's the code.
Just like the real... Yeah, arcade students are not alive right now.
In the west.
Alright.
Here I am.
Guys, we have to win one.
We can't end the stream until we win one, guys.
That's like my own... That's like the only thing.
Wait.
Alan, no.
Join Alan.
I... No, Alan.
Alan, why?
You actually know how to play.
You actually know how to...
Wait.
Why am I by myself?
Guys, I'm gonna...
Guys, I...
Guys, come on, guys.
Guys, I'm not playing this solo, guys.
I'm not playing this solo.
There's no way.
Alright.
Funzo, you must know what you're doing.
Look at this nerd.
He's all alone.
What a loner.
Couldn't be me.
Wait.
Look at this.
Oh, he has a buddy now.
He has a buddy now.
It's okay.
He came back.
He came back, chat.
Okay.
I think, honestly, I definitely did the best with SwordGuy.
SwordGuy was definitely, like, my best one.
Ooh.
No, I wanna be blue.
We're team blue.
Alright.
I believe.
This is it.
This is where we win.
He was the...
This was the character where I actually clutched it.
This was the character where I actually clutched the 1v2.
So, I believe.
I believe in this.
Alright.
Alright, Darius.
I need you to tag in.
Oh, that song.
Yeah, his rate...
I mean, I literally won my first round with him.
The very first round I won was with... literally with this guy.
So, I'm gonna be a miss...
What the fuck?
Okay.
Yay.
I did my job.
Don't worry.
In 2 seconds, I can help you again.
Watch this.
Boom!
You're welcome!
Wait, tag me in!
Tag me in!
Tag me in, tag me in!
Yeah!
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm joking.
Yeah!
I did it!
Your turn.
Okay,
don't worry.
I got you.
Boom!
I did the thing.
Wait, tag me in!
Wait, no!
Is that gonna kill him?
I did it.
Your turn.
Oh my god, I'm so good.
Bro!
I need to get in here!
Get in here!
Guys, I did it, guys!
It's not kill-stealing!
We literally worked together!
It is the yesterday of all time.
Oh, me!
Don't worry, I got you in two seconds.
Oh no.
Don't worry, I'm coming over to help you.
I think I did it.
Oh shit!
Wait, tag me in!
Tag me in!
No!
Don't worry, there's still hope.
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you.
I got you!
Wait.
Oh.
It's okay.
No!
I died purpose- Oh no!
Bro, why did you tag me in?
Bro!
I wasn't ready!
You gotta, like, warn me first before you tag me in!
Like, I wasn't ready!
Actually, bro.
What are you talking about?
I am doing my best, dude.
Oh shit!
I did not mean to do that!
Sorry, bro!
Bro, that was an accident!
That was an accident!
I'm sorry, man!
Oh shit, he missed.
Wait, what?
No!
Bro, what happened?
Bro, what's going on, bro?
Bro, did they adapt it?
Guys, do you think I threw there?
No, right?
It's my teammate's fault.
He did not warn me before-
It's not me, right?
Nah, that can't be me.
See?
I did that.
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Okay.
What the fuck?
What did I do?
I don't even know what did I do.
What the fuck did I- What he- Yes!
No!
I died!
The Metroid League experience.
I don't know about you guys, but I got the two kills myself.
Like, it can't be me, right?
No.
No, I did my part.
I'm pretty sure.
It's- It's my team's fault.
I wasn't even ready!
Like, he tagged me in when I wasn't even ready!
I was not prepared to be tagged in there.
I- I was not ready.
Like, all I'm saying was that I didn't have time!
Alright.
It's okay.
This is it.
This is a new dream duo.
It is!
I wasn't ready!
He didn't give me like- He didn't- He didn't give me like a- You know what?
Maybe Ahri.
Okay, I'm gonna be Ahri.
Alright.
Like, I need like- I need like a warning.
You know?
Like a five second warning.
Whenever I'm tagged in.
It's- How am I throwing?
I don't understand.
How was I throwing?
I got my- I got my- I got my twos.
I even got my twos.
I didn't even need a one.
Okay, nice.
Okay, we can skip that.
Thank god.
I was gonna say.
Oh, shit.
Wait, he knows what he's doing.
Okay, no, I got hit.
Nevermind.
What the fuck?
Which one?
Nice.
I did it.
What the fuck?
You can do that?
Okay, don't worry.
I got you.
Where am I?
Don't worry.
I'm right here.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, that throw is insane.
Okay, I got hit.
Why did you call me in?
Bro, why-
Tyrius.
Why are you taking so much damage?
Tyrius, no!
Oh my god.
Oh, this is not fair.
Bro, what?
What did he do?
What the fuck was that?
Holy shit, what did I do?
That was so much damage.
Oh my god, but I almost clutched it.
I don't know what I did, but I almost clutched it there.
Don't worry, I got you.
I did!
I can still win.
Yes, they didn't expect it!
Don't worry, I can do this again.
They'll never expect it again.
But will they expect it again?
No, they never expect it!
Let's go.
Oh no, it's a...
It's a Yasuo.
That's right, you didn't expect that either.
What do you mean?
I helped!
Darius, please.
I don't want to fight him.
Holy shit, Darius.
Don't worry, I got you.
Wait, I have to fight Darius.
Why did you fight me?
Darius, no, I don't want to fight this.
Oh, thank God.
Why did he put me back in?
Holy shit, I got you.
Yes!
I did it.
I know.
He like, chucked me into the fight.
I was watching.
All right.
I didn't expect that, did you?
That's right.
Watch this.
You didn't expect this either.
Well, where am I?
All right.
Don't worry.
That's right.
Oh, thank God.
Wait, no!
Wait, does that hit me?
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
There's this.
No!
Oh, shit.
Oh, no!
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I don't know what I'm doing, but don't worry.
Do you think they know I don't know what I'm doing?
Shit.
I think they do.
I think...
Whoa!
I...
Please.
Come on.
Oh, oh no.
Did I block it?
Yes, I did.
No!
I could have...
Please.
We have to win at least one game.
We only win one round.
There has to be one person.
There's no way!
Are you... Oh no, this is training.
Guys, there has to be one.
There has to be at least one person.
One team.
Oh my god, wait.
Is it this?
Join cabinet queue.
No, that's the queue.
Oh my god, all the... all of his phone!
Wait, no, no, no.
There's one here.
Have we played with Lecce before?
Hey guys, we need two here.
Who doesn't know what they're doing?
Ideally.
Why did I get tagged in everyone else?
Alright,
I'll be the Yasu.
That's right.
No Yasu for you.
Alright.
This is fine.
There's no way.
I'm Yasu.
Yasu is clutch.
There's no way.
This is the... This is it.
This is the game.
This is it.
How do we skip the... Oh, there it is.
Okay, I really... Okay.
Is that me?
Oops.
I get the li...
I did it!
Woo!
Oh my god, I did it!
It's like Pokmon.
I summoned him in.
And then I did the thing.
Don't worry, I got you.
Oops, the fuck you mean?
Oops.
What do you mean?
I did my job.
That's right.
Did not expect that, did ya?
Don't worry, in two seconds.
You wouldn't expect this.
Okay, he expected it.
I shouldn't have telegraphed that.
I...
Okay.
I'll be ready, I swear!
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
I didn't get to see me.
Don't worry.
That's fuck you, right?
You didn't ever expect that.
Oh my god!
Wait, I think I'm gonna win!
Wait.
No!
Oh, wait.
Okay, don't worry.
Oh, no!
I took damage!
Why did you let him hit me?
Oh, no.
Guys.
Guys, I think I jinxed it.
I think I jinxed it, guys.
No, no, no.
No, this is it.
This is it.
This is good.
And then...
And then he'll never expect it.
Oh, oh, oh!
No, Ahri!
No!
Don't worry, I got you, Ahri!
They're on!
Wait, we did it!
Don't worry.
I got you.
They never expect that.
And I'm gonna do it again in two seconds.
Oh!
It's okay, I... I'll finish the job.
Oh, wait.
Wait, he has not take...
Don't worry, I have not taken any damage.
I will finish the job.
Oh.
Yeah, I got you!
Oh,
shit!
What did I do?
Wait.
Did I just do it?
What did I do?
What the fuck did I do?
Wait.
I did it.
Yeah.
You see that?
That's right.
Yeah.
I'm a gamer.
I don't even know what...
I comboed into a...
Yeah, I did that.
I planned it all along.
I put you guys in a false sense of security.
Yeah.
I can't believe you guys thought I did it.
I was just button mashing.
How... How could I button mash into that?
I don't know if you guys know this, but I am a Sajam Slam champion on my very first FGC tournament.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
She's emo, too.
Oh, wait.
I don't want to see this.
How did I skip the cutscene?
I don't like the cutscene for it.
Don't worry.
I got you.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
This is not what I wanted.
Stop.
So, yeah.
With the power of teamwork, we got this.
T-bag.
Of course, the T-bag.
Wait.
Where am I?
That's fucking right.
You didn't expect me, did you?
You thought I was going to do it on cooldown.
Because you're damn right I am.
Wait.
Tag me in.
Come on.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
You can't jump for it.
That's fucking right.
You thought... That's right.
Oh, you thought you could do it?
You thought you could just tag in?
That's right.
Because you can.
So easy.
So fucking easy.
Wait.
Tag me in.
Let me in.
Wait.
No.
I want to finish it.
Alright.
Please.
Yeah.
Wait.
That's right.
We're...
We're the power duo.
Thank you for hopping in.
Yeah.
That's the little sister experience.
Don't worry.
I got you.
They blocked it.
But I tried.
That's all that matters.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I got you again.
Yeah.
He blocked it.
But that's okay.
It's the effort that counted.
Wait.
No.
You're not supposed to take damage.
Ari.
What the fuck?
What's going on, Ari?
What the fuck, Ari?
You got me hit.
Did they adapt?
That's not fair.
Fighting game players.
What?
Fighting game players should not be adapting?
What do you mean they adapted?
What do you mean?
That should not be a thing.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
He knows what he's doing.
Oh.
He's doing those.
He's doing those and everything.
Oh, my God.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
What the fuck did I do?
I'll never know.
Did I do the same thing?
Oh.
No.
I just want to make it close, you know?
I'm just trying to make the game closer.
You know what?
I feel confident.
Ooh.
I was surprised.
Oh, you thought I was going to swap?
That's fucking right.
I'm not.
Because I am now.
Yeah, you thought I was going to swap it on the first try.
No, I'm swapping it.
I'm switching things up.
Oh, shit.
I'm not a... What the fuck is this combo?
Oh.
I can help you soon.
Don't worry.
I surprised the teammate.
Oh.
Yeah?
I can surprise you too.
Oh.
That's right.
The wind is here.
I don't know what that does, but it's here.
That's fucking right.
Alright.
Any moment now.
The combo is going to end, right?
Oh.
Oh, no.
Ahri, no.
I got you.
He blocked it.
Please, Ahri.
You can't die.
That's right.
I got you.
Wait.
What?
You didn't warn me.
You didn't warn me that I was going to do this.
I did it.
That's okay.
But I did it.
Okay.
But he's so good.
Oh.
No.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
Oh, shit.
No.
Ahri, you didn't do anything.
Why are you giving me a kiss?
Yes.
Oh.
I got you.
There you go.
God.
I don't know.
So, I'm fine.
I just wanted to say I was scared.
I have a whiteico to.
I do not.
I thought you guys are... I thought you guys are FGC players.
You're really letting an FPS gamer beat you?
Reported for toxicity.
What did you do?
Why did you boost your ego, Ethan?
Why?
Go to an actual lobby.
There's nobody in the actual lobby.
What do you mean?
Alright, your turn.
I tried!
Don't worry.
I'm here!
I did the thing!
Oh my god, how far is our win streak though?
Oh shit.
Maybe you should get a hit in first, bro.
That's fucking right.
Wow.
Hachi!
Bro, that's a little embarrassing, bro.
Okay, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait, wait.
Wait a minute, wait.
We didn't mean that, Braum.
We didn't.
Hachi, I didn't mean that.
Hachi, please!
I didn't mean that, Hachi!
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Oh, that's fine.
Oh.
He's running away.
That's fine.
It doesn't matter if you run away.
That's fucking right.
You're trying to try and keep running?
Maybe you should stop running away.
Oh, did I dodge it?
Wait, what?
I didn't block?
How did I not block that?
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Oh, what?
You're still alive?
I killed you.
Oh no, my teammate killed you.
My teammate killed you.
So easy.
That's fucking right.
Oh, didn't expect that swapper-ooney, right?
I hit you and then I swap.
The craziest fucking switch up ever.
And then I'm going to join in on the fight.
Swapper-ooney.
So fucking easy.
That's right!
Oh, he jumped?!
How did she jump?!
He knows how to jump?!
How is that possible?!
Don't worry, I'm coming in!
Easy.
I did my part.
Wait, tag me in!
Tag me in, Ahri!
Tag me in, I can solo him!
Tag me in!
Put me in!
Put me in, coach!
Coach, put me in!
That's fucking right!
Oh shit!
Oh, wait, why did you tag me in?!
Wait, wait, I didn't mean it!
I didn't mean it, I was joking!
Jk.
Oh shit!
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait!
I went out!
No!
Why did you tag me in?!
You know exactly what was gonna happen!
It's alright.
I think, like, I was clutching too much chat.
Rance broken.
Wow, another win?
Guys, fighting games are so easy.
Oh my god, the streak goes on.
Bro, can nobody defeat us?
I don't know, it feels like nobody can defeat us at this rate.
Hahaha!
He's growing smugger by the second.
What do you mean combo stealing?
That's right, I blocked that.
Oh shit.
Wait, you got hit?
Wait, wait!
Wait, I'm getting hit more than once!
Wait, this is not how- Wait, Ari!
Ari!
This person actually knows what he's doing!
I'm getting hit!
This guy actually knows what he's doing!
What was that?
How did you know?
Holy shit, how does he know two different characters?
Oh no!
I still got hit!
Who's my Ari?
They all look the same!
Oh my god.
Who let this real fighting game player into my lobby?
Wait, why did I not- Ari!
Why did you swap with me?
Oh, thank god!
Your turn!
Damn, Zoki, you sure blocked that so good.
Your face really makes for a good shield.
It's alright now.
Okay, if I lost, it's not because of me.
Oh my god, wait!
My person is doing all these combos!
Oh, I think this guy is an echo player.
This guy is so good, holy sh- Oh my god!
I can't face tech that hard.
Holy shit.
That's fucking right.
Win time!
I don't know what to do with it, but- No!
Ari!
I was not meant to do this!
No!
Ari!
How am I supposed to clutch this?
Oh, he's through!
No!
My win streak!
We got 1v2!
I can't believe it!
The evil- has been defeated!
No!
I should have unplugged this man's controller!
Who is he?
I can't believe it!
Alright.
Before we call it, I wanna watch some of you drag- Alright, who's the strongest dragoon here?
Who's the strongest FGC fighter?
Who's the strongest FGC fighter here?
I wanna see the best FGC fighter fight.
Who is it?
If you're the best FGC fighter, you go to this lobby.
The one in front of the big TV.
I wanna watch.
I wanna watch Chaos Muffin versus Alan!
Chaos Muffin versus Alan!
Get in here!
I see Alan get fucking shit on!
Chaos Muffin, you- You should be over here!
You too!
Alright.
Alan, that's not- Alan, get over here!
Alan, get your ass over here!
He'll destroy me so hard!
Would no one fight Chaos Muffin?
Who will fight Chaos Muffin?
Why are you all scared of him?
You fucking cowards!
If I get my ass beat by him, we all get our ass beat by him!
We all get our ass beat by him!
We all shall get our ass beat by Chaos Muffin!
Okay.
How do I watch this?
Is this it?
Okay.
He's not joining.
Does only the center cab have- Yeah.
How do I watch this?
How do we spectate?
I wanna spectate this.
I saw that guy in Minecraft once.
How do we spectate?
Anyway, I wanna spectate.
Oh, you have to hop in the center?
Wait, is it- How do I spec- How the fuck do I do this?
Oh, it's this.
Okay.
Toggle size?
It's loading.
How do I toggle it?
Oh, it's loading!
Oh!
How does it take you for every load?
It's still loading!
What the fuck?
Guys, don't fight yet!
Stand still!
I'm joining.
Guys!
Guys, don't load in yet!
I'm trying to- Oh, he hasn't joined.
Okay.
Okay, I was gonna say, everybody stand still.
So I can watch the fight.
Alright.
Don't be broken.
How can there be- Oh!
Alright.
Oh, what the fuck?
Can I make it fullscreen?
Like this?
Okay.
Alright, zoom in.
Which one's ChaosMuffin?
Just the average YouTube stream.
We're watching a stream of a stream right now.
We're- Wait, what?
Where are they?
Oh, it's like a cutscene!
This is pretty funky.
It is.
It's like, you know, like the- Oh, sorry.
That's my other foamboard.
I need another sticker on this foamboard!
It's not!
It's not strong enough!
Wait, which one's ChaosMuffin?
Which one's ChaosMuffin?
That's Blue's Clues.
That's Alan.
Is Chaos the Ahri?
Oh!
The one winning.
Get fucking shit on Alan.
Oh, shit!
Chaos!
T-Bag him!
T-Bag him, Chaos!
Wait.
Wait, Lecce, how come you couldn't do that?
Wait, is Yasuo your main?
Oops.
Wait a minute.
Why didn't you tell me Yasuo was your main if you could do all that?
Lecce!
Why didn't you tell me?
You mean to tell me I could've won even more?
You kinda sublocked it.
Is Yasuo one trick?
Ooh, the mix.
Report Doki for stealing his one trick.
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
Oh!
Damn!
Wait, that shit was sick!
That was such a cool super!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Wait, but Chaos Muppets got this!
Oh, thank god.
Okay, thank god.
That's actually a super sick super.
I really liked how that looked.
Yeah, and it's alpha, so it can always improve too.
The fact that this is alpha means it can always get better.
That's the best part.
I need to put more fucking stickies on my foam, my acrylic pad.
Not acrylic.
My acoustic panels, cause it keeps falling.
My acoustics is so loud.
It keeps falling.
Don't even let Alan...
Don't even let Alan get any HP back.
It could get worse?
The graphics?
How?
There's no way.
I feel like Riot has not actually failed in terms of like making video games.
Like every...
Even so, they'll just throw enough money at it to make it successful.
That's all they have to do.
They just need to throw enough money at it until it's successful.
I feel like the graphics will get better.
You know what I'm really looking forward to?
To see how they're gonna add cosmetics into it.
I'm looking forward to see how they add like add cosmetics into this fucking game.
That's like what they're good at.
They're so good at adding at doing like what's it called?
At like skins and stuff.
Just re... Oh, it's true!
They don't even need to come up with new skins!
They just bring...
Yeah!
Okay, Riot is very good at microtransaction.
But like, they don't even need to come up with new concepts!
All they have to do is literally just... literally just like bring the cosmetics from League into this.
Oh shit!
Alan, that's embarrassing.
Oh no.
No, the Yasu main!
That shit you should have told me!
You were Yasu main!
Holy shit!
He jumped over her super!
We could have killed this entire lobby!
Oh my god!
Guys, I think it's... I think it's like Lecce's fault for not telling me that, you know, he could have said that, you know, that's his main.
He's literally one V2-ing as Yasu.
Oh my god!
It's okay!
He's gonna clutch it right...
Oh!
Holy shit!
You got this!
Please!
Bro, the Yasu doesn't even take any damage!
Oh my god, bro!
This guy's insane!
This guy's actually insane!
Wait, that was my teammate!
That was actually my teammate!
Or it's his fault for being...
You're right!
You know, if you were a fighting game player, you should know all the characters!
Wait!
Alan got carried!
Alan got carried by my old teammate!
Oh my god!
That's embarrassing!
Chaos!
I can't believe Chaos beat me!
Alan...
Alan actually got carried!
Holy shit!
Oh!
Leche was...
Leche was actually the gamer.
He was the secret gamer in the end.
That was fun!
I had a lot of fun trying out 2x KO.
Even though it was on keyboard and not my leverless controller.
I mean, I won so many games!
I won so many games too!
So like, I'm pretty happy with myself.
I beat some...
I beat some players...
Some of my dragoons here who are FGC players.
Don't think I don't know!
You guys must have...
You guys had this code longer than me!
I literally got the code an hour before stream, guys!
And I beat some of them!
Yeah!
No, I might be a prodigy!
Guys, I think I'm just...
I think I'm gifted.
Okay, Toki...
Toki, please...
I'm...
I'm her!
Okay, Toki, sure...
That was fun!
I...
I really had a lot of fun.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun.
Um...
You are not her!
If anything, Lecce is her!
Hey!
But I was there, guys!
I was there with Lecce!
So that... that means something!
Bro thinks she's her!
Hey, guys!
I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
Um, it's so funny.
Uh, for next week's schedule, it's very funny.
The amount of people that added me regarding the Crow game...
I had... I had so many people add me and even, like, my... my staff and also, like, my friends were like, you should play this game!
Oh my god!
It's Crowki's game!
Anyway, next week, Crowki's gonna have their own stream next week, um, playing that Crow game.
That's the only... and also the... I'll be streaming the Wukong launch, uh, on launch, so I think the Wukong game is releasing at 7pm PST on Monday, so I will be streaming that too.
Anyway, guys!
I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
Um, I always have so much work to do behind the scenes, so I'm gonna be working... I'm gonna do some behind-the-scenes work after this stream, so I'm gonna call it here now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing, and if you stay up for me, head to the bed, cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!